- L'usage du français
est en déclin à Montréal
au profit de l'anglais.
Les deux langues font partie
de lréréalité quotidienne
de bien des travailleurs.
- Si je m'adresse à quelqu'un
qui parle juste en anglais ou
qui préfère parler en anglais,
onon va parler en anglais,
on s'adapte.
- Beaucoup le français,
quand même, entre nous.
Et sinon, oui, l'anglais,
d dépend, on travaille
beaucoup aussi avec des gens
à l'étranger aussi, donc...
- Pour renverser la tendance...
(applaudissements)
... François Legault
veut que 100 % des personnes
immigrantes choisies par Québec
soient francophones.
CHRISTINE FRÉCHETTE, ministre
Immigration, Francisation, Qc
OnOn va orienter nos mesures
de recrutement en fonction
de la connaissance du fait
français, en fonction
du fait que les pays seront
francotropes, donc ils sont,
par exemple, locuteurs
d'une langue d'origine latine.
- L'an dernier,
la province a accueilli
plus de 50 000 immigrants.
Plus de la moitié sont des
immigrants dits économiques qui
ont été sélectionnés par Québec.
C'est cette portion qui devra
être complètement francophone.
À l'heure actuelle,
près 80 % d'entre eux ont
une connaissance du français.
PIERRE FITZGIBBON, ministre
Économie, Innovation et Énergie
- Ce serait le fun d'avoir
100 %. Il faut être réaliste
pu i il faut balancer ça
avec les besoins.
- Le ministre de l'Économie
s'attend à ce qu'il y ait
des exceptions pour certainesenn
de travailleurs étrangers
hautement qualifiés.
- Il y a plus de 300 millions
de locuteurs francophones depars
croire que parmi ce bassin-là,
ceux qui voudront immigrer,
qu'il y en aura pas suffisament
qui correspondront aux profils
dont on a besoin sur lplplan
économique. Donc, pour moi,
c'est pas mission impossible.
- Mais est-ce que c'est réaliste
d'accueillir 100 % d'immigration
économique francophone?
- Bien, on pense que le seuil
actuel est vraiment raisonnable.
- La présidente de l'Association
québécoise des avocats en droit
de l'immigration craint
notamment que des candidats
qualifiés soient exclus.
Me STÉPHANIE VALOIS, Asso. québ.
avocat d droit de l'immigration
- On doit pas se limiter
à des personnes qui ont...
une langue francophone
parce qu'il y a des candidats
vraiment intesessants qui
vont contribuer à la société
québécoise tout en apprenant...
continuant l'apprentissage
du français ici.
- Leveverbes, est-ce que
c'est difficile, les verbes?
- La francisation, d'ailleurs,
est un autre élément important,
mais les nouveaux arrivants
ne peuvent porter à eux seuls
le fardeau de la survie
du français, estime
cet ancien professeur.
CARLOS CARMONA, Regroupement des
ororganismes en francisation duc
- Des étudiants qui sortaient
de chez nous après 30 semaines
de cours à temps plein,
donc 900 heures de cours, qui
parlaient, qui cmumuniquaient
en français. On les rencontrait
quelques mois plus tard et
ils avaient perdu une partie
de leurs compétences
parce que. a au travail.
- Comme quoi l'avenir de
la langue se joue surtout
à l'intérieur de nos frontières.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.